help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from timcast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
I want to jump to this next story from
the Daily Mail Mississippi's largest
city Runs Out of Water indefinitely over
180 000 people are left without drinking
water and can't flush their toilets or
take showers what after floods made
Jackson's Water Treatment Plant fail
Jackson Mississippi ran out of water
indefinitely leaving more than 180 000
residents of that water Governor Tate
Reeves announced on Monday the city's
failing water system was completely down
due to years of poor infrastructure
mayor chakwi antara La mumba said the
recent Mississippi flood strained the
city's water plan water plan so I I just
want to tell you this you know when I
tell people the education you're going
to need right now is how to survive I
hope the people of Jackson know how to
pull water from the air solar-powered
water condensation well I mean you don't
really need to do that you can just put
a piece of plastic at an angle and then
bend the bottom so catch humility out of
the air or you can dig tunnels
underground where the wind goes
underground and then condenses and then
creates like a puddle of water
underground yeah I mean like the basic
thing is you dig a hole you put a cup in
it you put plastic wrap and then the
condensation trickles down but they have
these big things you can buy they're
just they're just plastic sheets that
roll down into tubes you put it up and
in the morning all of the humidity
condenses then goes down you get some
water but uh anyway look I don't think
that's going to be practical for a city
of 180 000 people but when you see stuff
like this this should be a cold splash
of water in the face that uh yo we don't
live in in Elysium we don't live in a
world of infinite resources we live in a
bubble protected by people with guns and
machines that secure resources easily
for us the reality of the world at any
moment this could be gone and I've
talked about this because I remember
like 10 years ago in Ohio I don't
remember how long how long ago it was
there was an algal bloom and all of the
water became toxic because of the algae
and there was no water for 40 miles it
was I can't remember what city it was
was Cincinnati or something I think so I
don't know and so people were driving
out buying bottled water and then it was
all disappearing there was nothing
because you couldn't get your water
source went dirty there you know I I see
so many people who just live assuming
everything's always going to be fine
there's always water there's always food
I got nothing to worry about then one
day there's going to be a flood they're
going to have no water no food and
they're going to scream save me and no
one's gonna be there to hear it that's
the reality of what's going on right now
man
and by the way how much was it that we
just sent to Ukraine oh they're trying
to do it how much how much could that
have been used to
do the infrastructure and uh injection
for a little water a little decelling
yeah I mean like I don't know if you
remember Flint Flint Michigan when when
they lost their water source it took
years not years years of that thing to
recover and it left a lot of a lot of
kids damaged it took months to get
billions to Ukraine you know so that
that's good news I guess we can snap our
fingers and send money to a foreign
country that's not us put our troops on
their border pull our border patrol and
send them to Poland but uh fixed pipes
and Flint I don't know about that it's
it's frightening how particularly in
this this age we're in in the Biden
stagflation economy
how many people in this country live
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck I mean
it's it it with a turn a quick turn of
the screw here
um there's going to be even more pain
that we're already suffering I mean
there's a lot of people now who can't
pay their mortgages who can't pay their
rent
um and that message I somehow
you don't read much about that in New
York Times or see it on CNN or something
I wonder why I'm really concerned with
the student loan stuff because of this
because like if someone's struggling to
pay their mortgage and then they find
out that they got ten thousand dollars
siphoned away from them to pay for some
college guy that there's going to be a
class hatred just like Soviet Union man
I do not like where this is a mortgage
strike like in China
yeah and that stuff can spread like uh
as they say in China prairie fire that
scares the hell out of the Chinese
Communist party when people start
resisting like that yep
but you need more I suppose and they
suppress the information there but uh
yeah China's on the verge of collapse
I don't know man I kind of think that uh
people aren't really paying attention to
the supply crisis that's been happening
here in the U.S so I'm not surprised to
see a story about a city running out of
water
people so we we're having construction
done on the new headquarters and it's
been stalled it's been a year now I bled
you raised that because the last time I
was here was about a year we talked
about okay this is going to be really
cool going to your new studio and just
saying the other thing and it's like
Brian gets me into cars like where are
we going oh same old place what's going
on uh it's hard to get materials
nobody's working that's right my joke is
the rapture happened that's the only way
to explain it airlines are shutting down
there's no employees I went to go out
there are fewer people there are fewer
people everywhere I went to a diner
Saturday at noon and they were like
we're closed due to short staff I'm like
where are the people at how like people
Gotta Eat Right people got to pay rent
what's going on where are they so
jokingly I'm like they must have been
they must have gotten raptured and we
just don't know or something but they're
gone and so uh we're trying to get this
building put up and they put they it
they're a year behind a year behind
we're we're a year behind what's your
finished date now
the project stalled and this is and it's
because they're like the materials are
unavailable people people don't see this
stuff because you know look most people
aren't dealing with ordering steel for
instance or putting up a building yeah
so they don't see that behind the scenes
the core materials that we need did you
know that one of the largest aluminum
plants in this country shut down did you
remember that story I do remember that
was it 20 of us aluminum production wow
they said they couldn't afford the
electricity anymore
so and I'm like we're saving our
aluminum cans and you think yeah the
reason why they can't afford the
electricity anymore because the price of
aluminum has been driven down by
subsidized Chinese aluminum that's like
one of the things that I fought in the
White House you know we put in place uh
steel and aluminum tariffs to provide a
defense against that kind of stuff and
sure so here's what we do we take the we
take our cans yeah and we're smelting
them down to ingots we have aluminum
actually so I don't know someone's
apparently done that like I found a box
with with aluminum we are saving the
cans probably a recycle or something but
uh somebody actually it might be Chris
Chris he's melting him down in ingots
look I know there's a supply chain
crisis but it's actually ground to a
halt your new studio so uh it was
supposed to be done last year yeah like
a year ago and then they were like it's
delayed we have to wait we have to wait
and then finally in the spring they're
like we're going to lay the concrete
then they're like as now the concrete
foundation's up we should be able to get
the steel and get the building done now
it's August the uh 80 of the framing is
done and they stopped and left and
they're like we don't have the supplies
so now it's just sitting there stalled
again it's absolutely insane and I'm
hearing this for Tom from tons of people
saying that there's a bunch of materials
they're unable to get right now and they
have to wait let me refer you to carbon
dioxide in the graphene that we could
make out of it this I know I'm not like
focused on the step right in front of me
I'm kind of focused on the next third
step Fifth and seventh after that but
I'm like down to work with anybody in
the in the government I don't know if
the government's the right place to go
with this I imagine American industry
but it was always like Carnegie was a
private sector guy he didn't build this
the Americans didn't build the steel
industry well in America did Carnegie
what's it William Carnegie
um what do you think should I so I mean
let's let's uh let's take it to the
reality again what I did in the Trump
Administration I think everything is
saying underscores the need to produce
domestically okay and it's not just to
have the steel
factories here themselves but to have
the supply chains that go with it and we
got hooked starting back
1960s on these these globalized Supply
chains because it was cheaper yeah
that's the idea and no one ever
factored in the appropriate geopolitical
risk of being being dependent on a China
or Russia for energy or whatever
and it was all about
um
also cheap labor so that's why
everything got out there and you know I
spent four years in the white house
trying to buy American thing trying to
make sure I mean you take like one of
the one of the the achievements I think
we had was I did a buy American
Executive Order
um on on essential Pharmaceuticals okay
and there's there's three there's three
components to that you've got the the
finished dosage product itself right and
then you've got the intermediate
chemicals you need to make it and then
you got raw materials and the problem we
have
is that those first two stages are
completely almost all offshore okay as
well as a good part of the finished
dosage stuff so bringing that back very
difficult and the biggest biggest uh
two forces I had to fight were the big
Pharma folks you know they come in
they're freaking Gucci shoes in into the
old Eisenhower executive Bill let me sit
around the table and say hey we got to
do this like this was like early
pandemic is like we can't we can't be
dependent on these people and they say
no no impossible to do that they would
find it but then the FDA
would fight it as well because the FDA
is the servant of big Pharma like those
folks go through rivaldi doors and get
jobs there they got stocks there's this
and the other thing but the point is
that
if we source
our production as well as our supply
chains
then we won't be having the problems
we're having and and there's no reason
on God's Good Earth where we should be
short on aluminum and steel I mean we
got everything we need In Minnesota
where the people at yeah well The
Rapture happened well don't explain to
the people that that's an interesting
kind of issue and it is of itself
because
um
you know there's there's topics we
probably don't want to go here but it's
like there's reasons why people are out
of the workforce who got pushed out of
the workforce and
um this is a a political tragedy it's
not an economic tragedy it starts with
your Downstream politics here uh you
know politics maybe or Downstream to
economics what you're saying about the
medical production or biomedical
production I mean the Biden
Administration just signed this 11
million dollar deal to bring the is it
the last step of manufacturing the
monkey pox vaccine to the U.S from a
Danish manufacturer they're
manufacturing I believe in Michigan so
in some ways they are doing what you're
saying just only when forced to in
complete crisis
well yeah
I there's there's about 400 essential
medicines that that we need in our in
our cabinet and
um you know certainly okay great you got
the monkey pox done but but what have
you done lately for for all of the
um Advanced pharmaceutical ingredients
the API and the raw materials you need
for insulin for example or whatever
whatever it is and I'm I'm just telling
you that that for a lot of reasons that
stuff's the the most basic stuff's in
India and China because they don't have
any environmental rules and that's kind
of nasty nasty do and I was able to
there's a company called flow it's
p-h-l-o-w I was able to get
get some some grant money for them
and they had a process where they did
all three stages under one building so
you were able to get economies of scale
and scope across that and those are the
kinds of things I mean we've never we
can't compete as a manufacturing country
worker for worker what we have to do is
we gotta we gotta produce
more efficiently by having the the best
and smartest machines wedded to the best
and smartest labor and that's what our
focus is thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there